one two three four
[Music]
I've been bruised
and broken I've been torn into
I've been working
and running
then I have to run home to you
and I'm not living in your life
in mind
we've been getting across forever
we'll get it right this time and live in
the High Life
[Music]
you're always getting calm
but I'm Yours
[Music]
like
life
[Music]
these songs a love song
it's not an apology
but sometimes I hate you
reminding me of me
woman guess we're called from the same
clock 14 years in the same block nine
long months in your belly down to the
Kiln and I still wasn't ready three days
eight I arrived at the party smiling me
face you're welcome me Hardy back to the
Gaff and the Liberties wish them party
up with the knees girl we are caught
from the same cloth all you feel I feel
the same loss I see are always in the
Mirror Saint Angels devil sinner still
laughing my life without face up still
got
[Music]
you're alive
[Applause]
[Music]
highlights
behind
up living the High Life
[Music]
up on the highlights
[Applause]